bekommen zu einem drama auf der fohlen
koppe eine stute stück bei dem versuch
ihr fohlen vor einem wolf zu retten
der anblick des getöteten tieres ist
mehr als erschreckend familie bartels
ist nach der blutigen und tödlichen
wolfs attacke auf ihre tiere geschockt
in der nacht griff ein wolf auf einer
weide in uetze bei hannover ein fohlen
an die stute verteidigte jung ist
bezahlte dafür aber mit dem leben das
fohlen wurde schwer verletzt
das reden gesehen das raubtier
angegriffen wurde
warum rechten gucken wollen und da hat
dann entdeckt dass das fohlen das thema
tod ist stark verletzt wurde auch von
den wölfen wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
ist das fohlen muss mindestens vier
wochen in einer klinik behandelt werden
ob es dann wieder laufen kann weiß die
familie aber noch nicht falls nicht
müsste familie bartels das tier
einschläfern lassen
der jagdpächter hat sich die toten und
verletzten tiere bereits angesehen
es soll sich um einen einzelnen wolf
handeln der seit wochen in der gegend
hütet und ich möchte nun sprechen mit
insa bartels der pferdebesitzerin und
bier an ebeling jagdpächter dort als
allererste natürlich die frage frau
bartels wie geht es dem fohlen momentan
[Musik]
umständen ja man kann jetzt erstmal
warten damit das schlimmste ist und wie
ist und ob es weitergeht
wie lange das ganze
sie haben natürlich noch immer auch
andere tiere bei sich auf dem hof haben
sie jetzt angst um diese und
irgendwelche neuen vorkehrungen geplant
damit so etwas nicht noch einmal
passiert ja natürlich haben wir angst
und die anderen tiere bei uns auch alle
leicht und so schlimm aber es geht halt
nicht aus verschiedenen gründen und
natürlich hat man angst was wir
vielleicht nicht für die elfer brand und
oder auch noch andere pferde
ja man versucht alles mögliche wollte
ich hin wenn man wert auf abends hin man
hält die augen oft ein mann kontrolliert
ständig ja es ist aber auch schwierig
gegeben
schutzmaßnahmen dort durch gebühren und
immer auf einem hektar hat man ja wie
kann man das alles überhaupt aufbauen
das eltmanner ist sind dann nicht nur
dass da noch mehr auch andere ihre da
und wir werden ja auch in ihrem umfeld
nicht einigen
und ja schwierig schwierig ist immer mit
den schutzwürdigen wir haben gerade
schon gehört es gab bereits vorher
angriffe von wölfen vielleicht von
diesem wolf was können sie uns dazu
sagen ja hier im umfeld ist eine
ortschaft im in sind da gab es vor
einigen wochen bereits schon einen
übergriff auf einen shetlandpony das
wurde getötet und vor zwei wochen
ungefähr wurde dort ein kalb getötet auf
einer weide
also es ist hier ein wolfsrudel aktiv
und das führt immer wieder dazu dass
hier nutztiere offensichtlich gerissen
werden
im grösseren umfeld hört man von
weiteren schäden an schafen und ähnlich
nutzt hier nach weiden
das ist jetzt ja die zeit die sommerzeit
wo die tiere auf den weiden sind und da
nehmen die übergriffe jetzt zu weil die
wölfe auch ihre jungen haben und die
versorgung was kann man jetzt dagegen
tun wenn man überhaupt etwas gegen
dieses wolfsrudel tun kann
ja das ist ja schwierig weil es ja sehr
viele weiden mit nutztieren gibt und die
alle einzuzäunen das ist glaube ich vom
aufwand nicht vertretbar insbesondere
später einen verhältnissen zu den werten
der tiere und zu der fläche die
insgesamt betroffen ist wenn man sich
bedenkt in unserer dicht besiedelten
gesellschaft wie viel weiden es hier
gibt allein hier im umfeld sind mehrere
hundert tiere draußen auf den weiden und
dass man viele viele kilometer die da
betroffen sind
ansonsten kann man nichts tun weil er
wollte dem naturschutzrecht untersteht
nicht dem jagdrecht er ist auch eu weit
geschützt und sofern haben wir da eine
grobe vorstellung man kann die das
format ist gesagt hat nur versuchen
regelmäßig seine tiere zu kontrollieren
versuchen mit schutzmaßnahmen wie
elektrozäunen oder sowas zu arbeiten und
auch schon dass es wirkung 1